Violence can only be avoided with
peace and peace must be fair because
it is fair that Palestinian children
can also grow up in their own home
without the siege of the settlers because it is
fair that Palestinian families can
live in their own state without  The control
of a foreign army, neither war
nor occupation nor expulsion are the
answer. The only possible answer is
two states that live in peace. No
right to self-defense can
justify the murder of more than 17,000
Gazans, including 5,000 boys and girls.
We have met with the families of the
Israeli hostages, we have
witnessed the atrocity committed for
ever and also the horror in the kibbutzim. We
also share the pain of
Israeli society, that there be a
permanent ceasefire, that the hostages be
released, that water and  electricity
and food reach the
Gazan population that the wounded in hospitals
are safe from bombs and that
the displacement of refugees who
have nowhere to shelter stops. It is also
essential to reinforce sanctions
against ever in terms of financing
prohibit entry into  the European Union
to the settlers who attack civilians in the
West Bank support the
Palestinian national authority to assume
responsibility for gaza and lead an
international peace conference that
makes the two-state solution possible
and